Monogenic traits are traits that are significantly influenced by a
single gene. Monogenic meaning one gene. Now these are also
referred to as simple genetic traits and they're frequently found
in many introductory genetics textbooks. And that's because they are pretty
straightforward and easy to understand. We change one gene and
we get a change in a trait. Now what I'd
like for you to do is now that we've been
through about seven lessons in the course. See if you can
name one monogenic trait that we've covered so far,
or maybe one that you've heard of elsewhere. But even
if you're not sure, go ahead and try to think
of one and put it in the text box here.